I'm y'all substitute teacher Mr Garvey
I'm your substitute
and like totally let's get our math on
okay
teaching Center is brought to you by BMW
the ultimate driving machine
hello and welcome to teaching Center I'm
Boyd Maxwell with today's top stories
from the exciting world of teaching and
I'm Perry Schmidt well now we know the
long-awaited announcement by star
English teacher Ruby roof has sent
teaching fans Across the Nation into a
friendship I've enjoyed my time in Ohio
very much but I'm pleased to announce
that I'm taking my talents back to New
York City
thank you very much apparently ps431 has
made Ruby an offer she couldn't refuse
80 million guaranteed over six years
with another 40 million in incentives
based on test scores his salary puts it
right up there with Rockridge
Elementary's Katie hope and William Wu
out of Colgate back right
all right let's take a look at
yesterday's high school teacher draft
from Radio City Music Hall where central
Rapids High recipient of the worst test
scores last semester made the first pick
that was no surprise to anyone
with the first pick Central Rapids High
takes
calculus teacher Mike Yost from Tulsa
Teachers College
and just like that you're a millionaire
Mike Yost is an unbelievable story his
father living from paycheck to paycheck
is a humble pro football player kid was
a natural mathlete you know he's gonna
buy his mama house oh you know this oh
there's no way around now you owe your
mom
I don't know
today's highlight of the day is brought
to you by the 100 Black Angus beef thick
Burger on a fresh baked bun from Carl's
Jr and Hardee's
[Music]
now it's time for the highlight of the
day
[Music]
star history teacher Ashley Ferguson has
been one of them test scores over at
Vince cortical High okay
moderate forces fired first
can anyone tell me where this battle
took place now look at this she looks
left then right looks past the students
with their arms up in the air spots Max
near the back sees that even though his
hand isn't up he's engaged Max it was
Fort Sumter that's right oh come on see
what she did there she's bringing an
introvert into the discussion y'all
that's a teacher of the year play right
there that's right boy you know The
Confidence Game by Max by answering that
question correctly will enhance his
performance throughout the rest of the
year No Doubt coming up after the break
Mayfield prep trades Prince teacher
Janine Lotus Skyline High for a head
librarian and two Lunch Ladies to be
named later and we'll get the inside
scoop on the impendingteacher strike
crippled the season next up on teaching
set
thank you
strength courses through me
I am velocity
I am power
[Music]
I am a leader a Believer
I am the force that guides
[Music]
I am the gateway to what is possible the
path to the future
I am the future
the all-new 2015 6 series is here meet
the new teacher's pet
all right listen up y'all
the two teacher Mr Garvey
I taught school for 20 years in the
Inner City
so don't even think about messing with
me
y'all feel me
okay let's take a roll here
Jay quellin
where's jayquelling at
no Jay quella here
yeah uh do you mean Jacqueline okay so
that's how it's gonna be
y'all want to play
okay then
I've got my eye on you Jake
where is balake
here today
yes sir
my name is Blake
are you out of your goddamn mind
Blake what do you want to go to war but
lucky no because we could go to war no
I'm for real
I'm for real
so you better check yourself
be nice
is there a d nice
if one of y'all
says some silly ass name
this whole class is gonna feel my wrath
now D nice
do you mean Denise
you say your name right right now Denise
say right Denise correctly Denise right
Denise right be nice that's better thank
you now
a a Ron
where are you
where is a a Ron right now
no AA Ron huh
well you better be sick dead or mute a a
Ron here oh man
why didn't you answer me the first time
I said yeah huh I'm just you know I'm
just asking you know I said it like four
times so why didn't you say it the first
time I said a a Ron
because it's pronounced Aaron
you're done messed up Hey Ron now take
your ass on down to osak Hennessey's
office right now and tell him exactly
what you did
who oh Shaq Hennessy
insubordinate
and churlish
Timothy
present
I'm gonna take a little roll here Jay
quellin here
you are present Malaki
I hear uh-huh D nice here good
Jessica
thank you
Mr Garvey
what is it Aaron some of us need to
leave a few minutes early today
oh
oh is that so
um
and what
pray tell
is the reason
for this premature Exodus
yearbook photos
um we used to leave 15 minutes early to
meet up with our clubs
all right you know what that might work
with other substitute teachers but I
taught him in the city for over 20 years
now y'all want to leave my class early
so y'all can go meet up at the club
ridiculous
Mr Garvey God son of a [ __ ]
did I
Dr just then yes I'm gonna throw you out
the goddamn window
what Jay Quinlan Mr Garvey we're telling
the truth we we have clubs at this
school we have clubs for special
interests okay I see so y'all want to
play y'all want to play yeah okay we're
gonna play little games ah I play I'm
more than happy to play some games with
y'all anyone who's in a club
stand your ass up
uh-huh oh yeah there it is there it is
The Usual Suspects what the hell Club
are you in Jay Quinlan Future Leaders of
America
okay okay
how would you know if you're going to be
a leader
in the future is there a Stargate
in your bedroom can you travel through
time Jay quellin no just sit the flip
down
here's the thing I don't even know why
I'm about to ask you this
Malachi
what club are you in I'm part of the
Spanish club spit this you were by the
Spanish as Rion Seacrest which a big ass
Fraggle Rock hair
how about you D nice I'm in the chess
club
uh I'm sorry sweetheart you are not at
the gym
the mosquito bite Club maybe oh it's
hurtful truthful
there he is
a a Ron hey what club
are you a I'm the president of the Glee
Club why do I talk
your ass to osak Hennessy's office right
now before I bust a club up in your butt
okay
no okay I'm gonna go
mischievous and deceitful chicanery and
deplorable
this is principal O'Shaughnessy students
please report to the gymnasium for your
Club photos fake announcement now does
anybody in here have a valid reason for
leaving this classroom Timothy I gotta
go pick up my daughter your excuse
all right everybody just uh let's settle
down and settle in and like just totally
let's get our math on okay all right
guys so
um
somebody's got a little extra energy
yeah
Jimmy buddy hey buddy let's okay let's
just let's knock it off okay
he got me right
dude all right let's take our seat
that's great that's great
very good I'm just kidding you guys can
clap
that was awesome oh and I thank you I
thank you for the entertainment man
I don't want a harsh survive man
I'm gonna be honest with
I'm just pushing my buttons now it's not
Jimmy
you're driving me crazy
thank you
you want me to write your name on the
board
[Applause]
okay Jimmy do you want me to call
principal Martel
that would not be bitching would it
you know what
why don't you come up and teach the
class man
wouldn't that be awesome
no and then you know what I'm gonna do
Jimmy I'll just sit here how about that
Jimmy and then we can all watch how
you're being disrupted
oh I see that's supposed to be me right
all right Timmy okay I see that I did it
supposed to be me it's time to be done
Jimmy don't you dude
[Applause]
oh yeah
oh yeah
well this is you Jenny
um
give me five give me five huh how about
that huh that's you Jimmy I'm Jimmy
I'm Jimmy and I need attention yeah I'm
Jenny I'm Jenny hell look at him
I'm Jimmy I want attention we
can kill me okay
Mr flyer
principal Martel no what no no no no no
no he was Jimmy it was Jimmy Crystal
martelly hey it was Jimmy it was Jimmy
hey
hey
[Applause]
baby daddy
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
I
am a substitute
Mr Nostrand
but that might as well say No Nonsense
because I
I do not
play
now today will not be a day off
in fact today you will work harder than
[Music]
somebody call it here
and we're here to teach y'all how to go
down home [ __ ] right now [ __ ]
ain't being satisfied so check it quit
[ __ ] on that clitoris so damn hard
[ __ ] don't like that nonsense that's
like putting the tip of your penis in
the vacuum y'all need to chill on the
clitoris go around that business that's
like a button made of a million penis
toss now every [ __ ] like a cunnilingus
a little bit different vaginas I like
snowflakes snowflakes is different learn
yo [ __ ] snowflake ask your [ __ ] what
she wants then do what she says some
[ __ ] like it in a circle some [ __ ]
like it up and down [ __ ] like it hard
[ __ ] like it's soft communicate with
your [ __ ] meant to alphabet with your
tongue a b c d i mean she grab your hand
like she gonna pull your damn head off
stick with that letter I'm talking about
respect you don't want someone slapping
around your little homie
you with the hat yo how you like your
BJs damn dog all the time
shut the [ __ ] up that's cause penis is
easyness is hard they are confusing
imagine there's an explosion at the
envelope Factory
you need to lick away out the factory
but every bitch's flaps is different
earn your [ __ ] particular flaps slaps
be crazy
everybody flap need to be listened to
and then you will get out of the factory
a lie stay down there plan your
breathing like you're swimming you gotta
be talking about stroke stroke breathe
stroke stroke breathe
all right let's take a five minute break
when we come back we're gonna talk about
warming your [ __ ] up before you get
busy and that'll last for more than two
damn minutes take a peach and practice
practice on repeat take a picture
practice practice take a picture
practice
oh I think it's gonna work 30 down 3
billion to go
[Laughter]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]